hey 42 here on the 7th of October 1849 a
heavily intoxicated man was found lying
in the gutter outside a pub in Baltimore
as is traditional with intoxicated men
in gutters this one cut a fairly
unimpressive figure and he was muttering
to himself incoherently in other words
he could have been any drunk in any
gutter almost anywhere in the world but
this man wasn't just anyone he was Edgar
Allan Poe one of the greatest writers
who's ever lived and exactly how he
ended up in that gutter in 1849 remains
one of the biggest mysteries in the
history of
literature now I know what you're
thinking isn't it pretty bloody obvious
how an extremely drunk man ended up in a
gutter outside a pub but bear with me
because this plot is about too ficken po
was taken to the nearby Washington
Medical Center for treatment and it was
there that something odd happened or
should I say didn't happen considering
the state he was in everyone assumed po
was raging drunk but even the drunkest
of men will sober up soon sooner or
later whereas po remained in this same
Delirious incoherent state for 4 days
straight and then he
died by all accounts it was a strange
way to go especially since he was only
40 at the time but things were about to
get stranger still because it turned out
that PO had been missing for almost a
week before he was found in that gter
and to this day we have no idea where he
went or what he did in the meantime he
just seems to have
disappeared off the face of the Earth
only to turn up half mad and die a few
days later it's hard to miss the irony
that POS mysterious death reads like
something straight out of one of his own
stories and there are some genuinely
wild theories about exactly what
happened to him winter is the perfect
time to get stuck into a mobile game at
home and I've discovered this amazing
game that's available on mobile and PC
and you can seamlessly switch between
devices there are over 800 Champions
ranged ing from Lizard likee creatures
to elves and Orcs if you're into
collecting awesome characters with
beautiful gameplay click the link in the
description or scan the QR code on
screen and now rage Shadow Legends and
Monster Hunter are colliding in an
amazing limited time crossover starting
on January the 9th and finishing on
March the 5th players will be able to
collect five Monster Hunter themed
Legendary Champions everyone will be
able to get raffalos blad Master
legendary champion for free simply by
logging into raid for 7 days between now
and February the 27th players can get
the other four Monster Hunter theme
Champions via special in-game events so
check in game to see how you can collect
these amazing Champions the Cur city is
one of raid's biggest features since the
Doom Tower with 100 stages to complete
including stages where you'll need to
take down two of Rage bosses at the same
time click my link in the description or
scan my QR code on screen to get insane
bonuses available only via my link
you'll get two epic Champions with my
link the first is light sworn a very
strong epic champ champion from the
sacred order and Juliana after reaching
level 15 additionally once you're in
game use the promo code raid xus for new
and old players come find me under the
name 42 and you can join my clan and
we'll be Legends together so just hit my
link in the description and I'll see you
on the battlefield and thanks to rage
Shadow Legends for sponsoring this video
but before we get on to post death we
should probably talk about his life
because what a life it was most people
think of Edgar alen po predominantly as
a horror writer but the truth is he was
so much more than that he
single-handedly invented detective
fiction was one of the founders of
sci-fi alongside authors like Mary shell
and Jules Vern and he was one of the
first people to explore the art of the
short story it's also been largely
forgotten that before he took to
storytelling po had an extremely
promising career in the military and he
might have gone right to the Top If he
hadn't have got himself court marshaled
on purpose he was also something of a
polymath and despite never having any
formal scientific training he used the
power of His frankly frightening
imagination to somehow predict the
origin of the universe and the existence
of black holes several decades before
the actual scientists came up with them
and then there's what is probably my
favorite story about Edgar aleno one
that fittingly enough comes from Beyond
the Grave I don't want to spoil it but
let's just say it involves an accidental
prediction so utterly spectac ular some
people genuinely believe po might have
just been a time travel stick around
till the end of this video and I'll fill
you up on those details and trust me it
will be worth it but for now without
further Ado this is the remarkable
incredible near unbelievable life story
of Edgar Alan
Poe Edgar Poe was born on the 19th of
January 1849 in Boston Massachusetts
early life for little Edgar was well it
wasn't great his father left a family
home and never came back when Edgar was
just a year old and a year after that
his mother Elisa died of what is today
assumed to have been tuberculosis just
in case that wasn't a bad enough start
to life for Edgar and his two siblings
they were then split up and sent to live
with three different families presumably
thoroughly traumatized by this point
Edgar ended up in Richmond Virginia with
Scottish Merchant John Allen and his
wife Francis he was never formally
adopted but the Allens did have Edgar
baptized and that's where he acquired
the missing third of that catchy name of
his the Allens were one of the
wealthiest families in all of Richmond
and Edgar was given an education
befitting his new station including a
5-year stint in the UK where he studied
at some of the finest boarding schools
around in 1826 he attended the
University of Virginia founded 7even
years earlier by some bloke called
Thomas Jefferson where he studied
ancient and modern languages po had
always been an excellent student but
like many young men attending University
for the first time rather than
concentrate on his studies he decided to
go absolutely bloody mental instead
within a year he was forced to drop out
after amassing substantial drinking and
gambling debts that was pretty bad but
things were about to get even worse
because like many filthy rich men John
Allen absolutely detested the idea of
wasting money in order to make sure his
foster son couldn't Fritter away any
more of it losing it cards Allan simply
turned off the money tap which is why at
the age of 18 a flat broke Edgar Alan
Poe decided to join the Army taking the
stereotype of writers being frail
bookish types and bayonetting it into a
billion bloody bits po took to the Army
like a duck to hoist and Source he made
short work of the lower rungs of the
military ladder and was eventually
selected from amongst 500 of his peers
for promotion to Sergeant Major the
highest rank possible for a
non-commissioned officer in 1829 he left
the Army to enroll as a Cadet at the
United States Military Academy better
known as West Point but he lasted less
than a year after realizing his true
calling was not with war but
words rather than just you know quit he
decided to go out with a bit of a bang
by deliberately getting himself CAU
Marshal exactly how he did it is a
subject of some debate but according to
Legend he was dismissed after turning up
but naked to a parade ground drill sadly
that story is probably apocryphal most
historians agree he simply ignored his
duties until Lo and charge were left of
no option but to give po the heave ho
with his military career behind him he
made the Bold decision to dedicate
himself to writing fulltime that might
not sound like such a big deal these
days but back then it was practically
unheard of PO is widely accepted as
being the first American writer to make
a living solely from writing in other
words he quit a promising career in the
military to do a job that didn't even
exist yet Perhaps un surprisingly it
didn't go all that well
it wasn't that he found it difficult to
find buyers for his stories he didn't
the trouble was they paid like
copyright law was still in its infancy
meaning rather than pay local writers a
fair price for their work American
magazines could simply print stories by
British authors for free there was
precious little Point paying po pretty
penny when you could lift literature
straight from the limes try saying that
10 times fast with stories and poems not
yet putting food on the table let alone
paying the rent in 1835 Po got himself a
job as a staff writer and critic at the
southern literature messenger
enrichment the chance to earn a steady
albeit fairly pitiful wage was a major
break for imposed career or at least it
would have been if he hadn't got himself
fired inside the first mon for being
drunk on the job not that he let
unemployment get him down he put his new
found spare time to good use by finding
love and when I say love I mean he
married his cousin his 13-year-old
cousin yeah the happy cousins I mean
couple were wed by a minister named aasa
Converse that random fact has no bearing
whatsoever on this story but I had to
include it because history should never
have forgotten that neck beard a month
after getting the boot from the
messenger po was rehired and this time
things went much more smoothly Not only
was he able to get many of his own
stories and poems published he also
started to make a name for himself as a
literary critic an absolutely Savage
literary critic over the next few years
he bounced around several different
Publications writing stories and poems
and just generally eviscerating the work
of his colleagues for fun in 1841 he
casually invented an entirely new genre
of fiction when he published a short
story called The Murders in the room
morg it was both the first modern
detective story and the first locked
room mystery and it featured a character
called C August dupon an eccentric but
brilliant amateur detective who used his
almost Supernatural analytical abilities
to solve crimes if that sounds a tad
familiar it's probably because a certain
rather famous fictional detective was
very clearly inspired by Po's creation
without dupon there would have been no
Sherlock Holmes by the way it's thought
that PO came up with the idea for dupon
whilst doing a bit of detective work
himself in figuring out the trick behind
the chess playing automaton known as the
mechan IAL Turk I covered the Turk back
in 2020 and it's one of my favorite
videos on the channel I highly recommend
you check it out if you haven't already
in 1843 po entered a story called The
Gold bug into a national competition it
won the grand prize pocketing him a cool
$100 probably more than he was ever paid
for a single piece of work but its
impact was Far More Than Just Financial
in fact you could say the gold bug was
indirectly responsible for saving tens
perhaps hundreds of thousands of lives
a key element of the story's plot
involved a real cryptogram that once
solved reveals the location of some good
oldfashioned buried treasure
cryptography wasn't well known in those
days and in the decades after its
publication the gold book would
introduce tens of thousands of young
readers to the concept for the very
first time amongst them were Leo Marx
and William fredman both of whom read
post stories as children and found the
idea of cryptography so fascinating that
in later life they went on on to work in
the field Leo Marx became chief
cryptographer for the Special Operations
executive a secret organization credited
by General Eisenhower with shortening
the second world war by at least three
months and William Friedman along with
his wife Elizabeth went on to become one
of the most influential code Breakers in
history as the chief Crypt Analyst at
the signal intelligence service during
the second world war his teams broke
multiple Japanese ciphers saving
countless lives in the
process in 1845 Po's now legendary poem
The Raven was published in the New York
evening mirror and it was an instant hit
it's often reported that PO died
penniless and in obscurity but only half
of that is actually true like most of
his work he didn't make much money from
the Raven selling it for just $9 but it
immediately struck a cord with readers
All Over America and Beyond transforming
po into a household name almost
overnight to this day the Raven remains
one of the most famous and best Lov
poems of all time as well as one of the
most quoted and parodied pieces of
literature in history even now
references to the iconic poem pop up all
over the place from The Simpsons to the
NHL and from League of Legends to Star
Trek three years after the Raven po
published an essay called Eureka it was
a major departure from his typical style
covering of all things his ideas about
the makeup of the universe itself you
might think that's a fairly unusual area
of interest for a writer with zero
scientific training and plenty of people
at the time agreed in fact Eureka was so
downright odd that some viewed it as
compelling evidence po was losing his
marbles little did they know that many
decades after Po's death Eureka would
prove to be one of the most unexpectedly
insightful essays ever written now that
might sound like a pretty big statement
but well see for yourself in the mid
19th century when Eureka was written the
overwhelming scientific consensus was
that the Universe was infinite
unchanging and eternal but Eureka
describes a dynamic ever shifting
Universe born from a single primordial
particle that expanded outwards to
create all matter in other words edar
aleno predicted the Big Bang almost 80
years before scientists did hidden
within the complex Labyrinth that is
Eureka are also Illusions to the
relationship between energy and matter
the role of the the speed of light in
the universe the existence of black
holes and the concept of a cyclical
universe that's born and reborn over and
over again it would be decades until any
of these ideas appeared in scientific
literature Eureka is so remarkable that
even today Scholars aren't really sure
what to do with it alongside all the
brilliant bits po also got plenty wrong
but what he got right is just uncanny
normal people just shouldn't be able to
randomly guess the deepest darkest
secrets of the universe just by having a
bit of a think whilst sitting on the
toilet Eureka turned out to be one of
Po's last major works on the 27th of
September 1849 at the age of just 40 he
got on a train in Richmond to go to New
York where he was living at the time for
the following week nobody had any idea
whatsoever what happens to him until he
turned up in that Baltimore gutter days
before his
death
one theory is that he may have been
subjected to something called coping a
kind of political fraud in which victims
were kidnapped and forced to vote for
certain candidates in elections often
multiple times whilst wearing a variety
of disguises that might sound well
mental but cing was actually quite
common in Baltimore at the time and it
would at least explain some of the
stranger details of the case like why po
was in Baltimore in the first place and
why he was wearing someone else's
clothes many victims of couping were
beaten or applied with alcohol or drugs
a combination of which might also
explain Po's apparent delirium when he
was found and were perhaps even the
cause of his death couping is certainly
one of the most popular theories about
Po's death and disappearance but it
isn't the only one po was buried in an
unmarked grave in a Baltimore graveyard
but as the years went by and his
popularity as a writer continued to grow
it was decided that he needed a more
fitting resting place in 1875 a fancy
Monument was erected nearby and POS
remains were were exume so that they
could be reburied at the new sight when
his body was moved the local Gravedigger
claimed he could clearly hear Po's brain
rattling around inside his skull at the
time nobody thought anything much about
it but these days we know the
gravedigger's story makes no sense
there's simply no way a human brain
could have survived 26 years on
theground without the composing but if
it wasn't Po's gray matter bumping
around inside his head what was it well
it's possible that little lump may have
been the calcified remains of a brain
tumor if that's true it might explain
Po's odd behavior and delirium in the
days before his demise and it would also
give us a clear cause of death there
have been literally dozens of other
theories over the years including
everything from mercury poisoning to
rabies or even murder but the truth is
we likely never know for sure what
exactly killed Edgar Allan Poe and
perhaps it fitting that the death of the
great mystery writer will itself forever
remain a
mystery oh and speaking of mysteries
it's time I told you about the greatest
coincidence in history in his all too
short life po wrote precisely one novel
The Narrative of artha Gordon Pim of
nanit the book tells a story of a
stowaway on board a wailing ship called
the grus at some point the grus is badly
damaged in a severe storm that only four
of the crew survive and over the course
of the following few weeks the drifted
sea they slowly begin to succumb to
starvation the crew managed to bring a
few Provisions up from the flooded
depths of the ship including a small
torus but it isn't enough and with no
land in sight and nothing else to eat
they eventually turn to cannibalism they
draw straws and the loser is the
youngest Survivor a boy called Richard
Parker who was killed and eaten by the
others the novel was published in 183 38
and it was largely a flop but almost 50
years later something incredibly weird
happened in 1884 a yacht called a minion
sank somewhere in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean just like impos novel
four men survived to sinking and just
like the novel soon enough they were
starving as look would have it they
managed to catch a turtle but the fresh
meats didn't sustain them for very long
okay so it isn't quite a torus but it's
close enough
eventually the survivors grew so
desperate they decided one of them
should be sacrificed for the good of the
others and just like in po novel it was
the youngest member of the crew who was
chosen and ultimately
eaten pretty remarkable right but I know
what you're thinking it's a pretty weird
coincidence but the biggest in history
there must have been dozens of cases of
cannibalism aboard ships in the years
since po died it's hardly a miracle that
one of of them involved the same number
of crew a toris turtle and the youngest
member being sacrificed but there's one
piece of information I haven't told you
yet something that transforms this from
a quirky coincidence into something more
than a little bit spooky I didn't tell
you the name of the crew member who was
eaten just like in post story his name
was Richard
Parker what the actual
by the way if that name is ringing any
bells it might be because the Tiger in
the life of pie is also called Richard
Parker orur Yan Martell chose it as a
kind of Easter egg to pay homage to the
greatest coincidence in literary history
and if you happen to have read the book
or have seen the film you'll know
exactly how fitting that name is Edgar
aleno struggled for most of his life to
realize his dream of becoming an author
it's an enormous shame that he never got
to find out quite how spectacularly that
dream would eventually come true true
today he is universally regarded as one
of the greatest authors who ever lived
and his influence on Modern fiction has
been so great that without him many of
the stories we know in love would never
even have existed what a tragedy it is
that he died so young to fill our world
with his stories never
more thanks for
watching don't forget to click my link
in the description or scan my QR code to
download raid today and get insane
bonuses only available via my link